Okay.
So how did your work on disgust changed the way that you looked at things?
Fundamentally mean you gave some indication of that already,
but what else has changed?
So since I was coming out of a,
of a psychological literature that was very focused on,
on sort of secular,
secular ethics about justice and fairness,
and then I began studying,
discussed and looking at the broader moral domain that almost all societies
have,
that then also led me to think about,
well,
okay,
if disgust is a reaction to things that seem to be degrading.
So an interesting element of discusses this notion of degradation that there are
always these vertical metaphors.
Um,
uh,
image discussed,
brings us down and discussed it.
So a lot of some religious practice in Judaism and Islam and Hinduism is about
preparing your body to approach God and uh,
purification.
And so that led me to think,
well,
if there's an emotion which is about seeing our lower base or animal biological
nature,
is there an opposite emotion?
Is there an emotion that we feel when we see some manifestation of a higher
nobler nature?
And I was just beginning to think this,
when I moved to Uva,
I got my first job at University of Virginia in 1995 and I read,
uh,
the set of Thomas Jefferson's letters.
And in one letter he describes,
he describes the feelings you get from reading great fiction.
He advises a cousin of his that he should buy fiction for his library,
not just,
you know,
serious works of law and philosophy.
And he described,
he says,
Eh,
doesn't,
uh,
he,
he describes the feeling of,
of,
uh,
of uh,
having your sentiments be elevated.
Does it not dilate your breast or giving an open feeling in your chest when you
see these acts of beauty and kindness and gratitude?
I thought,
wow,
that's exactly yet.
Um,
and so because I've been studying discussed,
I then started studying its opposite,
which I and some others called moral elevation.
So this is kind of vertical metaphor of elevation and degradation and it snaps
onto the body too with regards to,
that's right.
High Low,
uh,
clean,
dirty.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's a beautiful pairing.
And so having this language of elevation and discussed just really has helped me
see a lot of things.
I just,
I can just see a lot of things happening.
It allows me to,
like,
even in,
you know,
manipulate,
like of applying for a grant proposal.
Like it I can get very good at like having an elevating ending and you know,
to,
um,
uh,
to end with a note of uplift.
Um,
and so it just brought it,
it just broadened my thinking about morality.
And this was around 1995 and so again,
it just prepared me so that,
um,
uh,
and I'd already been to India by that point.
I spent three months doing research in,
in Orissa,
in eastern India.
Um,
so it just broadened my thinking and that's what allowed me finally to
understand conservatives because I had always been on the left.
I hated Ronald Reagan.
Um,
I thought Republicans were stupid and evil and it was only when I had gone to
India and really tried to understand a traditional religious,
hierarchical gender stratified society.
Tried to understand it in their terms.
They didn't try to just bring in my own,
my own western left,
you know,
left leaning perspectives.
Um,
that I was,
and this was all under the guidance of Richard Suede or my postdoc supervisor at
the University of Chicago.
We did a post doc.
Um,
it was only then that he was able to,
to,
to sort of get inside their minds and their moral system and see that there were
alternative moral worlds.
They each had their own logic and that was the metaphor I came to it.
You know,
at the time,
you know,
the matrix movies were very popular.
So the metaphor,
the Matrix as a consensual hallucination made a lot of sense.
It's waking up with the idea of just speaking about moral matrices have a
different moral matrix,
better grounded in biology and biology in the sense that it gives us the
potential.
It's like the building blocks of this matrix can't be just anything that comes,
it comes from our experiences,
our embodied experiences.
And again,
George Lakoff is the,
is the master of,
of,
of that thinking.
And so it was only then that I was able to now listen to conservative talk radio
and Christian religious radio and see,
rather than just saying,
oh that was stupid terrible.
People say like,
Oh wow,
yeah,
I can see that they're striving for certain versions.
Right.
So you started to understand their metaphorical language essentially.
That's right.
And that was like kind of like my,
you know,
on a great awakening or scales falling from my eyes.
But you know,
since well it took a few more,
it took a number of a lot more years.
But eventually I kinda just like pulled out the implants from my eyes and I
stopped seeing everything through a partisan lens and I'm not on any side now.
I'm just trying to understand what that is.
Well,
it's really useful.
It's really useful to understand that there are actual reasons why people see
the world differently and that you can't just easily say that one is right and
the other is wrong because the liberals are correct when it comes to borders,
that if you thicken them too much and diminish the information flow,
you risk making the society so static that any radical environmental
transformation will sink it.
It's the case,
but the conservatives are right in that you pay a big price with regards to
newcomers and new information with regards to risk to exposure to contaminating
while to contamination period,
but also to contaminating ideas.
And so then I've always thought,
you know,
the,
the environment itself moves back and forth like a snake in some sense.
And what we're trying to do is stay on the center of its back.
And the only way we can do that is by people,
by having people pull to the right and say,
be careful.
And people pull to the left and say,
well,
yeah,
but be open with that dialogue and the,
the exchange of information that that dialogue allows,
we can maybe specify the center of that moving target and stay and stay well and
stay on the back.
Let's,
yeah.
Okay.
So that's a really complicated metaphor with the snake,
but I think it's,
it's,
it's a perfect way in to what's going on on campus and to why viewpoint
diversity is so important.